fire sale potentially in new york it had
been reported that the jets were not
going to do anything by way of
entertaining
trade offers for sam darnold until they
evaluated the incoming
quarterback draft class if that's true
it sounds like they've finished their
evaluation of the incoming draft class
and they like who may be available
with the second overall pick here is
general manager joe douglas from earlier
today
talking about sam darnold
i i will answer the call um you know if
it's made
and so you know
as it pertains to sam i mean i like i
said
sam sam's a we think a dynamic player in
this league
um with unbelievable talent and who's
really really
um has a chance to to
really hit his outstanding potential
moving forward
but um you know like like i've said
earlier um if calls are made i i will i
will answer them
[Music]
not exactly the best poker face but you
got to get the word out somehow and
hey if you're going to talk you're going
to talk i'll answer the calls i'm not
going to hang them up like the texans
are doing with desean watson so
sam darnold in play and yeah it hurts
the jets leverage but they must be
confident that
there are multiple teams that would
maybe bid against each other and you try
to get something for sam darnold if you
are going to draft a quarterback and
it's not like they have to be coy
about drafting a quarterback because
they're going to get trevor lawrence or
zach wilson
if those end up being the top two guys
the only question is who's left where
you need to be
very coy is if you fall in love with one
of the two guys you can't let anyone
know it
because then somebody could try to
leapfrog you but to do that they'd have
to get the jaguars to trade down
which i doubt they're going to do so
long story bearable the jets are going
to be able to get a
quarterback with the second overall pick
in the draft and they're going to get a
guy who's probably going to be pretty
good
and they're going to see what they can
get for sam darnold and short of saying
please please please make us an offer
douglas makes it clear
he he is not going to turn anyone away
who knew there were so many talented and
phenomenal quarterbacks in this league
mike and if that's the case then why is
everybody looking for one right
so we keep hearing this from gm's and as
you've pointed out
gm's do lie i prefer saying gm
say what is the truth at the time this
is the truth at the time
they think that sam darnold's a
phenomenal talented quarterback
check back with us in a couple months
maybe a couple weeks
and we may have a different opinion of
that after we draft zach wilson with
that second overall pick mike
they're totally non-committal and sam
darnold he is on the trade block
and the question for me is well two
questions one
is what are they going to get for sam
darnold considering
what the eagles got for carson wentz
and two are they in play for deshawn
watson if he comes on the market i guess
that depends probably on when the texans
would be willing to trade deshaun watson
but i think they would have to be
in on that if that happens before the
draft otherwise i think you are going to
rule the jets out of being again we go
back to the
texans seem to do this sooner than later
because you're going to rule the jets
out of that if they draft
a quarterback at the second overall pick
well and and
sims who loves zach wilson believes the
jets should run to the podium with that
that name on the card if he's there at
number two and everyone expects that he
will be there at number two and not
trade the picks uh that pick and others
and darnold or whoever for russell
wilson or deshaun watson go with zach
wilson and you only have to give up the
second overall pick in the draft to get
zach wilson not other things but but i
i'd like to think that that they'll
have all of that fleshed out by the time
we're in the
two or three weeks before the draft and
i i wouldn't rule out them
trading darnold earlier well earlier
than the draft if someone comes along
now and says
we want to get our quarterback situation
addressed we want darnold so we can make
a move
with our other guy you know if the 49ers
are the ones who decide they want
darnold
and they want to try to do something
where they could trade jimmy garoppolo i
don't think they'll be able to because
no one's going to want that 25 million
dollar
compensation package this year but i i
think that
the jets don't need to wait until they
have
their quarterback with the second
overall pick to move darnold they could
move darnold
march 17 401 pm eastern bottom line is
darnold's in play anyone out there
that's exploring their options
darnold is clearly in play now it's
possible the jets want too much for him
and sharing here's what they gave up to
get him
to move from six to three three years
ago i remember that trade happened on a
saturday morning out of the blue six
weeks before the draft
it did from six to three they had to
throw on top of the pile
three second round picks three second on
picks to go up three spots
number 37 number 49 and a second round
pick in 2019
to move up three spots and they got to
forget about that
if they're gonna try to trade donald you
can't say well we gotta hit back
everything we gave up you know no it's
gone it's done it's a sunk cost
get what you can for darnold and move on
and hope that you can maybe get
bears and 49ers bidding each other up or
49ers and seahawks if the seahawks are
going to trade russell wilson elsewhere
or 49ers and jets
or texans excuse me if the texans decide
they're going to move to sean watson
whatever it is
i think that that you know
there's there's value in
moving quickly before anyone who
potentially could be interested in sam
darnold pivots to another option
yeah you know sam darnold was rated
highly in that draft i know
but you know i looked at his college
career and said i'm not sure why the
jets are trading up for this guy at the
time
and it worked out that it hasn't worked
out
uh for the jets i do wonder though mike
how much of it is the talent around him
because when i look at this roster and
i've looked at this roster over the past
few years i just don't see the talent
there
and that's why i think that they can't
get in the desean watson conversation
because they need all the draft picks
they can
they can get to build this team they
need a team they can build around a
quarterback
and they can do that on a rookie
contract with the quarterback which
would be a zack wilson they can give him
time obviously to develop
and use the future draft picks to build
a team around him but
you know darnold didn't have a whole lot
of talent around him he didn't have a
whole lot of talent in the offensive
line he didn't have a whole lot at
receiver he didn't have a whole lot at
running back there were just so many
holes on this roster for him i do wonder
how much of it was him
and how much of it was the talent around
him and that's what we're going to get
to find out going forward because i do
think he ends up with potentially a san
francisco or chicago or one of those
teams that has more talent and he'll
have more of a chance to succeed and if
he can't do it there then we
throw it off as a draft bus but at this
point i still would like to see him go
play
somewhere where there's some talent and
see what he can do
mike hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports